wir wollen dieses Problem lösen und da
macht Thorsten frei richtigerweise wie
ich finde darauf aufmerksam dass von
diesem Individualrecht auf Asyl im
Augenblick vor allem die profitieren die
stark sind junge Männer die sich auf
diese Flüchtlingsboote begeben können
Frauen
ältere Menschen Kinder bleiben zurück
und das sind diejenigen die unsere Hilfe
wirklich brauchen wir wir müssen dabei
bleiben dass wir ein Land sind das auf
der Welt hilft aber diese Hilfe darf
auch nicht missbraucht werden und sie
wird hunderttausendfach Missbrauch noch
einmal wir müssen nach Wegen suchen
dieses Problem zu lösen und dieses
Problem wird nicht kleiner das wird
größer
[Musik]